I want to kind of close the loop on that explosive
story from last week. Last week, I notified you
that there is another call that now is playing a
role in the investigation taking place in Georgia,
another call in which Donald Trump called the
investigator in the secretary of state's office
in Georgia again to talk about I need a couple
thousand votes and there was a lot of wrongdoing
and we won by a lot and we won this by a lot. And
all of these different statements that call, which
we learned about last week, we have now learned,
was found in a trash folder on the computer device
of a state investigator, which raises new
questions about whether there was an effort made
to actually suppress the fact that that phone call
took place. CNN reports that discovery of the call
came after state officials originally said
they didn't think audio of the call existed.
And it turns out that it did exist. It was in the
trash folder of an investigator involved in this.
And it is the recording in which Trump
pushes on the investigator, Francis Watson,
claims of widespread voter fraud and trying to
influence the investigation and subsequently
really trying to overturn the results in Georgia
so that the electoral votes in Georgia would go
to Trump instead of to Joe Biden. The
audio file is from a December 23 call.
We listened to it last week and the call is
between Trump and investigator Francis Watson. It
was discovered as the Georgia secretary of state's
office was responding to a public records request.
The Washington Post first reported the details of
how the audio emerged. Watson was asked, did you
delete this? Why did you delete it? Why was it in
that folder? It was uncovered only due to a FOIA
request. Did you plan to come forward and say this
exists because there's a big difference, if you're
an investigator between saying, hey, I have this
call versus hitting delete and relegating it to
your recycle bin, presumably for future deletion.
Now, of course, we could say, you know, if she
really meant to eliminate the record, she would
have cleared the recycle bin. I assume that by
a full folder of deleted files, they're talking
about a recycle bin or equivalent. It's all very,
very strange. And CNN previously reported that
in that December phone call that's at issue,
Trump was urging her to find ways to give him
Georgia and saying she would be praised if she
were able to overturn those results. And we now
are going to have to see what the the meaning and
significance is of this. Last week, the bombshell
was the call Trump made to Brad Raffensperger
wasn't the only call to Georgia officials before
the call. The Brad Raffensperger Trump actually
called Francis Watson and said much of the same,
which is wow. So now we know this was not a one
off call. This was a series of scheduled phone
calls. Now we learn that we learned of the audio
because of a FOIA request, and it was in a
deleted files folder on Frances Watson's computer,
which starts to change maybe the course of this
investigation. Where maybe the investigators
actually need to be investigated, so it's getting
increasingly complex and increasingly muddied and
I asked this question. I'm not saying this
rhetorically. Are there investigators in Georgia
that can actually really investigate this
objectively? You know, Brad Raffensperger, his
office, the secretary of state, they're clearly
not the right place because they are participants
in all of this. Brad Raffensperger was the one
Trump called to try to influence on the results.
So we know about investigator Francis Watson,
but now we learn Francis Watson had deleted
audio of the call and it was in the recycle bin or
something equivalent to it. So that's probably not
the right person to investigate how it ended up
there. So. So who exactly needs to be brought in?
Do you need some kind of special investigator?
Do federal authorities need to come in? Do they
would they have jurisdiction? I don't know. But
this needs to be figured out because this is
just Georgia. But every week we are learning more
that makes that raises more questions rather than
answering them about exactly how planned and
coordinated was this effort to try to overturn
the Georgia results. There's also now emails
that have come out referencing upcoming phone
calls with Donald Trump's then chief of staff,
Mark Meadows, in Georgia, which again suggests
the phone calls were happening. But the phone
calls involving Trump were happening after other
preparatory phone calls were already made.
This may have been a much larger effort to,
after the fact, try to steal Georgia from Joe
Biden. Hopefully we'll learn the full scope of
it at some point in time. We're going to take
a quick break. Stunning video from Senator Ron
Johnson coming up after the break. And we will
also talk about this is strange, the announcement
of urination on Fox News. I know it sounds
crazy, but we'll talk about it after the break.